this program is brought to you by Emory
University he still had movement
limitations he could he could move his
hand but he couldn't extend his hand
very well nor could he do the things
that he really likes to do which is
drawing sculpting he's an artist and
that's what he likes to do and he
couldn't really do that so when he first
came to us we knew that there was a
really nice room for improvement he is a
phenomenal artist and has been drawing
beautifully since he was 12 and the
thought of him not being able to express
himself creatively was taking half of
his life away
Spencer's been here hasn't missed any
date comes promptly at eight o'clock in
the morning and it moves all the way
through so now at the end of this we're
actually going to do some evaluations on
Monday but he has begun to draw he's
begun to spontaneously you use his hand
and that's something that's really a
port Bay yeah it's it's a it's a game
like it's it's a um I mean I just have
fun every time I've come here we went
into it from the first day saying you
will recover completely and he has done
wonders since then uh I mean I've just
been taking it one day at a time like I
mean that's all I can do
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University